[Music]  okay  i'm peter parker  i am spiderman  what's your name  peter  you're gwen right quincey  i love you and you're always gonna be my  best you're gonna make enemies people  will get hurt  you don't give people hope you take it  away  i'm gonna take away yours  are you okay  yeah  i'm okay  are you okay  [Music]  stop arguing both of you peter one peter  two peter  [Music]  we're gonna lift you up on a cherry  picker and you're gonna jump off  they became super villains it's just so  funny i fell into a super collider gotta  be careful where you fall  to work with them is honestly the  highlight of my career me and toby  arrived and all of their arms were just  open  [Music]  [Music]  red butterflies with toby and andrew  hoping they would sign up  [Music]  you